[Music]
welcome to another episode of carol west
super late edition as you can see i'm
fresh off a comic-con and was the hell
of a day um
shout out to read them for me as I was
leaving the place ran into her and she
allowed me to know that um XM was in the
building I didn't know that hexamers in
the building I saw a sideshow I really
was a super impressed with sideshow
stuff but that's a tale for another day
but I got a chance to meet Alex from red
Titan and now he's the new marketing
manager Media Manager of XM studios I
met Brian from XM studios that effect
some studios and a couple of other guys
you're all going to hear the washing
machine finishing in the background
listen this is a super late edition I
just needed to get it out to you guys
because if I don't show you my passion
you know what am i without you guys
right so okay what you see behind me is
the strongman the muscle the duel with
all our hustle inside the x-men Colossus
the silent type big strong silent type
six seven muscular draws this is what I
was growing up as you know as a child
little-known fact whenever we we talked
about what meat powder would you have if
he was able to be a mutant or something
like that
besides super speed I always like yo
Colossus identify with him because
I draw strong tall big and never really
into all that you know drama stuff to be
honest with you so I always felt that
you know Colossus represented me only
thing is he's Russian so on this Premium
Format oh the custom is where you met me
from x-men 500 and yeah this guy right
here that's the suit day he's been
wearing they've been using more recently
come from the old school suit
I have three other Colossus that are
actually no two other easy tart so it's
three Colossus actually to be honest
with you on to sideshows the new
sideshow one is coming and the original
Premium Format sideshow C cream going up
the steps that's right baby
so um yeah let me get this out to you
guys needed this statue to go along with
my mutant road I'm doing the whole
mutant room
shout out to Alex shout out to geo shout
out to mr. X shout out to all those guys
that are as part of this great community
I had a wonderful time at Comic Con I
thought was a blast at a better time
than I did last year it was outstanding
the kids got tons of magnets tons of
magnets if you're there they got these
magnets for a dollar you get twenty the
set of 25 for 20 bucks there's a lot of
steals in there man you just got to walk
around I will tell you to go to the back
of the East hole and just you know just
just go there to look for those deals
because the other side of the hole it's
all about gouging your pockets but if
you're trying to you know save some
money and make some stuff happen you can
definitely do it
I picked up a bunch of books
picked up a bunch of books so I'm gonna
get into these books you know I was uh
super impressed with the Thor books and
also there's one book that I've always
wanted
shout out to my main man dr. doom it's a
boom quest heaven versus Iron Man so got
that got a couple of stats of nice
tattoos I was looking for statues we
didn't have the ones that I wanted but I
wound up getting some posters from my
room as you can see this is the Marvel
poster I'm gonna get that uh
laminated and put mounted and on
Michaels and this is the DC side let me
get that mounted and put it framed up
and get that all done up properly as you
can see the eyes is red I'm finished
guys I did it for you did it for me did
it for the family it's a wonderful day I
mean if you really about this life
you're really about those comic books
and feel really about these statutes if
you're really about your passion go
follow your passion at all times this is
Kayla West see you next week when I
bring you that uh that one woman I said
I was gonna bring her but my boy came
this week I won them all for eBay he
showed up this week and you had to get
these he has a hole to switch out heads
the exclusive head is the worst thing
that you can ever imagine I was not why
why would I put this on his body that's
made out of metal it looks absolutely
horrible you have seen the videos at the
end I'm not gonna do no pictures stuff
is going up kognito
thank you catch you guys later next
week's cast 1ls out Kara
[Music]